these saucers it's something people can
explore are these balloons people can
understand a balloon maybe they're all
this maybe everything that's happened so
far has been this and maybe now we can
dismiss it or maybe we could say it's a
military thing it's sort of the same
thing in that it's approachable it's
relatable it's you don't require
Advanced quantum physics to understand
it
um first of all what do you make of
these things and is it potentially at
its core a giant psyop designed to
distract us like the bread and circus
set bread and saucers look the thing is
there are two basic doors into the this
phenomenon one of is indirect evidence
and the other is direct evidence
if you ask me if you go by direct
evidence
um with everybody owning a camera in
their pocket you have to say that this
is nonsense
because there is no direct evidence
that's high quality there's no high
quality data in the public domain that's
right so let's just say that from the
direct evidence perspective this is
nonsense it doesn't exist it's very
silly
okay now you switch your lens
you say there seems to be an
overwhelming amount of indirect evidence
like psychotically overwhelming and I
was unprepared for this until I started
looking at it I have no idea how we I
mean you can get rid of people who see
ghosts and people who have a need for
attention and you're left with people
who don't want to talk about it whose
lives have been destroyed and
you know particularly some very kind of
modest and modest cognitive gift folks
who seem to be able to act at the level
of Brando which I don't believe
I believe that these people have been
hurt
um some of them with by who with
necrosis we don't know
um but according to Gary Nolan he's seen
damage paths through tissue that
correspond to crazy stories where the
story actually has a physical Trace
um I would say from the indirect
perspective I don't think that we're
capable
of
faking this at this level
even if we wanted to even if we wanted
to fly you know SR-71 blackbirds and
their successors and we wanted a story
so in case anybody sees one
you know the jig isn't up so I've never
seen a subject that has that profile
zero direct evidence overwhelming and
direct evidence
somebody smarter than me has to call it
and in terms of probability in a
Bayesian sense between getting hearings
on the ecohealth alliance versus getting
Public Access
no why do we have a government like that
I mean I think a lot of this flows down
from government not all but a lot of it
does
sources and methods has become the bane
of our Democratic existence I'm
convinced that there is an issue of
privilege around many of the things we
cannot resolve you cannot have this many
things
shoved into sources and methods so that
the public can never figure out what's
going on and classified and put into a
garage sources and Method and we have
this you know we have an incredibly
incredible structure for avoiding the
Freedom of Information Act
where we have private companies the
private companies are entrusted with
secrets that you can't afford to hold in
government
so in the same way that you know a rich
person will set up an irrevocable trust
and say what assets I don't have the
assets penetrate this right you know and
the answer is the person doesn't have
the assets a container has the assets
and that somebody is in control of the
container directing the container to
make loans which are you know taxed
under different structures and uh so the
person is unlimited liability living an
incredible lavish lifestyle with no
assets and so my feeling is that the
government has figured out the foia
issue which is like what information we
don't have any information but it seems
to me if you know if there were hyper
intelligent aliens or something huge
um you know kind of malevolent entity on
Earth that they couldn't find a better
way to destroy Earth than than sort of
undermining our faith in science and I
feel like we're doing that ourselves
the cowards in science are doing that in
particular you know a short time ago
uh I was against public health and
people thought like
how can you make it what is that I want
to explain what you mean Public Health
not
just funding for you know we have a
culture of non-scientific behavior that
involves manipulating massive numbers of
people
um
because both War
and pandemic
are two places where you cannot make a
Libertarian argument you can't say well
whoever wants to go can go you know good
luck with that then you it's going to be
a self-estinguishing argument
so there is a sort of sacred obligation
when invoking Public Health saying you
all have to do the following thing right
and unfortunately this
this appeals to people who have who are
willing to forego income for the
privilege of telling other people how to
live their lives so it selects for the
wrong element
ideally what you would want is people
who are loathed to tell other people how
to live their lives who only invoke this
when it is absolutely necessary but good
luck convincing
uh people who are you know two clicks
away from Pure libertarianism to go into
this public health field so we
absolutely need Public Health
but we can't afford
fouchy style Colin style public health
and you know what that is and dashics
you know and and it's the manipulation
of people invoking science
to tell people to do things that you
claim are in the best interest the
social welfare function of your of your
nation
[Music]
thank you